wow it's already Friday and what a great
show we have for you Walter Kern is here
his work shows up in libraries more
often than horny homeless guys
Dave McDowell is here the only part of
her that's high strung is her banjo
that's here she knows how to balance a
checkbook I'm sorry I meant to say throw
up in a cab
[Laughter]
and there's Tyrus he once did the
electric slide at a wedding there were
no survivors I apologized for that
so the whole gang is here my favorite
people I'm so lucky and why am I lucky
because I'm surrounded by amazing people
but also have you seen the Johnny Depp
defamation trial he's suing his ex-wife
Amber Heard for calling him a wife
beater allegedly you want some low
lights here's some low lights after the
wedding there was a dinner dancing and
drugs you can't say that you carry
cocaine in that box no but it looks like
it would fit some cocaine you would
sometimes drink whiskey in the mornings
too right
during this time period
um I
I you know I mean isn't happy hour
anytime I don't believe that I'm the
only human being that's ever punched a
door or
broken something on
my side of the bed was human fecal
matter ah talk about airing dirty
laundry
so yeah it's sad kind of gross kind of
riveting but it's also kind of inspiring
so bear with me on this first we all
grew up watching Deb so naturally we're
going to be curious to what's going on
it's not like we care what Peter DeLuise
is up to
remember him and there are some ugly
things in this case there's video of
depth smashing Furniture dad punching a
wall lots of drinking and drug use a
finger getting sliced passing out
swearing screaming bottle throwing
hitting
what Dana Perino would call a quiet
night at home
enough because it's weird to turn
people's suffering into entertainment if
I want that I can read cat's diary that
is when kilmead returns it to me he told
me it's a combination of Judy Bloom and
Clive Barker
but I feel dirty when I explore other
people's pain and also other people's
poop true this might be the first time
we've ever seen on TV people talking
about other people crapping in their bed
on purpose Depp calls the ACT a grumpy
someone should alert Snow White of this
immediately she was on the phone and
they were
making a
a wonderful point of just how funny it
was
that um
I thought that some human being had
actually
dropped a
grumpy
on to the bed
and they were yeah they were yuckying it
up they were laughing about the whole
thing and I really didn't
feel like
I deserved that
well I guess she wanted to show him what
Gilbert grape's been eating
[Laughter]
of course everyone has dirty laundry in
an ugly divorce in this case the dirty
laundry here was in fact really dirty
laundry and the whole world shared her
trip to 21 dump Street
but there were other times when you
could really sympathize with depth for
example like why did he give drugs to
Marilyn Manson
one of your good friends that you've
taken drugs with before is Marilyn
Manson right
we've we've had cocaine together maybe a
couple of times
okay okay
um pills right
with Marilyn Manson
um
I once gave Marilyn Manson a pill uh so
that he would
stop talking so much
I know what Judge Jeanine is getting for
Christmas
but there's a bigger story here beyond
the CD salaciousness the fact is death
is humiliating himself for a good reason
he's bearing the most pathetic saddest
part of his life because it he feels it
must be done he's got to empty himself
out and not the way Amber did on the bed
spread it's like chemo he realizes the
treatment is hellacious but it's the
only way to beat the cancer so he's
burying his horrible existence warts and
all to billions of strangers how can he
do that well somehow he's immunized
himself against the effects of
embarrassment
and that's a superpower there's nothing
you can do to him that he hasn't done to
himself it's like Superman hoarding
Kryptonite before you can use it against
him
when I watched him I found myself
somewhat liberated for a few reasons one
is obvious that unlimited wealth Fame
and good looks doesn't make you immune
to suffering so I got something to look
forward to
but also embarrassment hits all of us
from the shopkeeper to the shoplifter
from the moving van driver to the movie
star and that should bring Comfort to
your life that we're all equal under the
harsh cruelty of our own fallible nature
give us any embarrassment of riches and
we could turn it into an embarrassment
of embarrassments but what makes you
immune to suffering is your ability to
cease judging other people even as they
judge you that's why this testimony
helps all of us once you realize that
even big stars are susceptible to Life's
humiliations then you realize that life
is hard for everyone you might be
luckier than him you might not be maybe
you screw up maybe you make a fool out
of yourself but the only person who
really judges you is you fact is people
overestimate how much others notice
their mistakes now it doesn't feel that
way when it's your mistake but people
are generally too consumed by their own
problems to dwell on yours so when I
watch dep I see a human sacrifice an act
of Liberation for all of us whether he
knows it or not he's embarrassing
himself for all our sins fact is I'm a
weirdo and I don't care if anyone judges
me for that since I won't judge them in
return that's freedom because we're all
hopeless Sinners and fools and humans
Depp is doing the best performance of
his career performing a sacrificial act
for us he's saying I'm not just like you
I might be worse and no Yachts or
Mansions can save me he's accepting the
Oscar for being a flawed human being
then slapping himself in the face
the result you see that we are in this
thing together and nothing drives that
point home better than someone else
taking a dump in your bed
the only difference is Johnny's sheets
have a higher thread count
let us
guess he's written eight books which is
impressive Until you realize killmead's
written seven
novelist in literary critic Walter Kern
this Southerner won't eat an alligator
but she'll wrestle one Fox Business
anchor digging McDowell
three-legged chairs call her unstable
Fox's contributor cat Tim I didn't know
they could talk and his Barber has to
use scaffolding my massive sidekick in
the nwa's world Television Champion and
author of The it's new book just Tyrus a
memoir in stores or Memoir who cares
it's in stores April 26th Iris
ah time to in this is the ideal time to
invite Johnny Depp on the show Walter
right I think he's perfect for this show
now and you really bought his act yes I
did I mean that was like a sermon that
you'd see on Oprah yes I mean yes yes
we're all flawed and so on yes aren't we
well I'm not but he is
is he Brave or nuts for doing this this
is not a divorce hearing this is a uh
about slander he didn't have to do this
so he's causing all of this laundry to
come out is that brave because he needs
to clear his name or is it nuts I think
it's one long personal ad for the most
screwed up lady in the world
um I mean he this is a mess this is like
a trip to The Monkey House these people
spent their marriage throwing food
bleeding and having diarrhea
I mean they didn't need a marriage
counselor they needed a trained
zoologist
[Music]
but but you know uh the thing is Amber
Heard has yet to be heard right but
she's been she's turd yeah but because I
have a theory with these uh celebrity on
Celebrity uh trials that whoever's more
famous wins
um and so after seeing Johnny's
performance and seeing how much you
bought into it I I think he's a sure
thing to win
um so you think I'm a sucker the pauses
that I heard Johnny uh they using were
the most deliberate thespian pauses that
I've heard outside of Pirates of the
Caribbean yes I mean the guy winds it up
then he holds you in suspense then he
drops the grumpy yes I love that by the
way
Tyrus though when you see somebody that
successful dealing with horrible
problems doesn't it give everyone hope
yeah you know what your monologue was
was spot on and I I agree he's obviously
very dramatic but there has to be a
sense of
I get it and I think that's what you
captured because I get it you know he
there are some things it is better to be
known as a drug doing weirdo yes than a
domestic violence guy right you know
like it's he that's the that's what he's
fighting against it has nothing to do
he's never gonna get a dime from her
yeah he's not it's not even about that
it's about what would you rather be you
know and he would rather all his stuff
come out him looking weak I mean him
they're embarrassing him even the stuff
that's on his behalf as a as a man he
looks terrible right so and the
cross-examination of the request drugs
right drugs right that to me when I hear
those kind of questions
they don't their case isn't as strong as
this because they're trying to get
people to go like oh he's a disgusting
human being because he does drugs with
Marilyn Manson so clearly he's a wife
beater right and he's saying no I'm all
these things because of my relationship
and I handled it wrong him throwing that
we all we've always been that we've all
punched the cabinet kicked the door went
outside and said what the hell in some
cases just went outside and never came
back
you know everyone has been in that in
those situations so I think it's the
performance of his lifetime because it's
his life he'll never get a movie again
if he's known if you're known as a
sexual harasser a domestic violence guy
you will never work again but a drug
addict you can get some work yeah that's
true that's true Dagan uh what do you
make of this so far do you care did you
care at all about this or I follow it
cared so much I laid on my sofa prone
covered in dog hair should have been
vacuuming there was a dirty wee pad on
the floor and I didn't even get up to
take it out and put it in the trash
shoot I watched two days every hour of
his testimony on Direct one day and on
Cross this is after I got home from work
because one I'm almost his age and he
was kind of my go-to you know I lay in
bed before I went to sleep at night
thinking I'm going to meet him in a dive
bar at Virginia Beach when he's filming
a movie and I'm gonna be his but now
he's getable for me yeah
potentially
and by the way he's also that what we
have witnessed is very relatable like
who what chick hasn't like gotten up in
the morning and there's some dude in
your kitchen wearing a Richard Petty hat
his mouth is purple from drinking so
much red wine it's eight o'clock in the
morning he's getting in a fight with the
paper towel holder he's kicking your
toaster oven and then he storms out of
the room but in my case I gave him fifty
dollars to go buy more wine and then he
just disappeared never came back
and they call me a novelist
I'd buy that book
um
ancient is is what is important
step comes off as self-destructive which
is sad but he doesn't come off as
sadistic which is what she wants and
what she kind of comes up as in a way
what are you with I mean the dump in the
bed is unbelievable yeah right and it's
kind of huge for me because
I'm like you know what I'm not like
difficult to handle and crazy like I
thought I was I'm I am a chill girl yeah
I I never ever thought I it turns out
I'm well adjusted easy going chill walk
in the park type of girl uh because I
not only have I never done that I've
never even thought about it I've never
like I I don't think I've bragged about
always using a toilet for probably 30
years like since yeah you can since I
was a toddler now I can start bragging
again I always use a toilet yes yes you
know the cat's Point that's another
thing too if you are doing those type of
things you're not in fear yeah that's
not someone who's afraid right that's
true that's true and I mean he had
recordings that I mean where she just
basically belittled him after he he said
you were hitting me and he goes
she those were hits not punches Yes Man
up like what yeah yeah what yes that's
great in court yeah your honor you know
I didn't punch her your honor I I hit
her no the difference sweetheart like
yes that would not go over well in any
Court yeah no matter how nice your voice
sounds yeah all right we're gonna get
our Bookers to give them a call come on
the show all right before we go we've
got some exciting news our live studio
audience returns Monday May 2nd and free
tickets are now available we're also
moving to a brand new studio it is
insane go to foxnews.com Gutfeld to get
your free tickets today hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else